the first part is the lemon sorbet but
the boys are not using just any lemons
our filaments amazing we use them all
the time in the kitchen because of
bloody brilliant arm they're not as
harsh as normal lemons and they got a
fantastic aroma for us the desserts are
such an important part but the lemons
will not just be used in the sorbet the
Amalfi Coast is in southern Italy and
that is where the boys want to take the
diners
we want to almost recreate Malfi Koo
smell that's the plan that's a little
magic plan that we've got in our head
the boys are making a lemon tea which
they'll pour over the kitchen alchemists
favorite the team's gonna be infused
with zest and lemon juice that's gonna
be poured on the pasta
what's going to be hot we're gonna pour
liquid nitrogen that's gonna flood the
room oh man this here wall bloody
brilliant it works really well this end
of the night spectacular could steal the
show if only they'd get it out on time
just send some food will you let's go
unbelievable everything hangs on the
panna cotta if it collapses so will
their dreams are becoming my best
restaurants panna cotta now I've seen
perfect so I'm really happy
accordion texture that consistency goes
clubbing
thank you the panna cotta is perfect and
now's the moment when it should all come
together kazimierz liquid nitrogen
wizardry has where my experts and the
diners
but is this just another casimir gimmick
the proof of the pudding is as ever in
the eating panna cotta and how was that
I mean for me it was delicious I mean
made to test you just move it and it's
got that wobbly nasteria
structure I thought the lemon with the
pineapple was absolutely brilliant and I
mean I like you I hate the gimmicky
normally I thought it served its purpose
I love the way they tried to get that
extra element in there so it's all the
senses its smell its didn't work that
yes it did work all the way in we didn't
harvest it wasn't just a gimmick when
you're very inventive I like those chefs
are sometimes it's just all invention
and no practicality has no purpose to it
now that had purpose and it had a church
and what a finale I mean it just looked
amazing yeah yeah the restaurant he
worked for the dish
for kisame and Prasad has taken a
shedload of drive determination and
skill to get to the final some are happy
they don't know who their plates are
empty that's why we are released now in
reality we're going to be indefinitely
we are I don't know if you want it's too
close to call again it's too close these
guys are faster lost tonight it's no
doubt about it
we're running around like bricks
literally run around like bricks in
there but we did that to show we can
cook in the dining room thoughts now
turn to which restaurant the diners
preferred and my team on the chef's
table have offered their expert analysis
the starter main course dessert was in
balance that it had finesse did it work
across the three courses okay it's two
widths in different ways by the time
they came to the end of their main
course they're in their rhythm they've
got those nerves on top of the fact this
is a master magician what are you
selling any clear who's looking winning
in your can best for sure about it